[Applaudissements]
lorsqu'on veut quelque chose tous les
jours maintenant sur votre présentation
conseils beauté à ozawa malaisie un
conseil beauté à donner ouais alors très
bien mais moi alors aujourd'hui il ya un
petit détail spéciaux les remarques et
ne sait pas faire chez vous
j'ai mis un peu de pression plus c'est
pas vous pouvez avoir chez vous passez
pas obligatoire non non j'ai un conseil
ça c'est vrai une fois par semaine si
vous pouvez un petit peeling chimique
c'est rien du tout un public qui vise à
sauver mais non absolument non alors là
c'est parce que c'est le nom commun le
gommage saabine un peu la pousse à se
frottent alors que peeling chimique
c'est une petite crème que vous achetez
vous de passer comme ça vous laissez
juste cinq minutes ce sont des acides de
fruits qui viennent manger des frites
particulièrement je vous promets que
derrière vous avez une peau magnifique
être que sur le village il faut pas
emballer un partout ben on survit
l'action visa pourraient faire des tutos
peut-être mais non je pourrais faire
mais ça c'est vraiment un truc à faire
une fois par semaine y en a des pas très
cher bien sûr qu'on a les traits
chercher la prairie dior tout ça mais
vous pouvez commencer dans avec vos
moyens
un pas très cher il faut merci pas très
bons conseils beauté
afat et lui à côté de lui vous vous
dites 1